In Somalia, a car bomb explosion outside the Presidential Palace in Mogadishu...
...claimed by Al-Shabaab Islamist militants...
...kills at least ten and leaves dozens wounded.
In Greece, the government launches an auction of four nationwide TV licenses,...
...raising a concern that four of the current eight TV channels...
...will have to suspend operations after the licensing process.
In India, a tractor trolley carrying 30 people...
...overturns in northwest Rajasthan state,...
...killing six and injuring several passengers.
In Brazil, as the impeachment trial...
...against suspended President Dilma Rousseff enters the fifth day,...
...homeless workers rally against the interim government in Sao Paulo.
And finally from Kyrgyzstan, a suspected suicide bomber crashes a car...
...into the gates of the Chinese embassy in Bishkek,...
...killing himself and wounding at least three embassy employees.